*whapoosh*
The For Real Markiplier: Hello everybody, my name is Pewwwwdiepie
Ah, frick, no, um Mar- Markiplier.
Don't worry about that whole exile thing everybody's talking about, that's completely
MADE-UP, that's not-
That's not actually happening. It was -  uh-
I got hacked (lol Golden.)
Everything's perfectly fine. I am signing calendars and creating content as normal.
See, everything is perfectly fine and as it should be, SEE?
It's my- my- the game I always played...
And the shirt I wore while I beat it a bunch!
See, this is COMPLETELY normal and everything is fine. (Yup.)
So don't worry about it
And don't yell at me for... over-committing to something. Because I didn't.
It's really NOT the case.
I promise.
I will admit though that I'm sick, so my voice is a little less handsome
Now my voice will sound a little more raspy and deep and you don't have to worry about anything!
See, look I'm playing the ga-
OH, there's stuff right there
OH NO, is that- oh look there's the animatronics just like in the videos
*ding dong*
Who could that be?
OH LOOK, it's the channel's mascot Little Box La-
*Warfstache doesn't almost fall off* Ti- Tiny Box Tim!
Wha- What, what are you doing here, Li- my- my little biscuit?
*End My Suffering.exe*
He never was very talkative.
Tiny Box Tim: Tell anyone about the exile and I'll cut you.
Thank you for Watching!